comme vous savez la langue française est
réputée pour sa complexité
une complexité qui ont fait la richesse
mais qui la rend aussi extrêmement
difficile à maîtriser
à tel point que même ceux dont le
français est la langue maternelle ont
parfois du mal à s'y retrouver et en
tant qu'enseignant amoureux de la langue
de molière
je peux vous assurer que s'exprimer dans
notre langue sans faire d'erreur relève
parfois de l'exploit militaire dans
cette vidéo je vais vous présenter 10
fautes de français que nous faisons
presque tous en savoir et je ne vous
parle pas de foot que tout le monde
connaît déjà comme je vais au coiffeur
ils croivent ou encore le fameux je sais
pas c'est quoi
rétablissement de la roue pour celui-là
bon là je vous parle de fautes que même
des gens instruits peuvent commettre des
fautes que vous faites peut-être ou vous
même alors est ce que vous serez capable
de repérer ses fautes
eh bien c'est ce qu'on va voir soyez
attentifs c'est parti et on voit pas le
générique n'ont pas aujourd'hui d'accord
puisque numéro un pour pallier à cet
inconvénient
eh bien non contrairement à ce qu'on
entend souvent on ne pallie pas à
quelque chose on pallie quelque chose
palier appartient à la catégorie des
verbe transitif direct ce qui veut dire
qu'il est suivi un cod et non d'un coi
on remédie à une situation mais on
pallie une situation oui numéro 2 j'ai
été au cinéma
j'ai été c'est le passé composé du verbe
être comme dans la phrase j'ai été
stupide de faire simple techniquement
cette tournure de phrase n'est donc pas
incorrect mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
le fait d'aller au cinéma qui est le
véritable sens de cette phrase on doit
donc dire je suis allé au cinéma et non
pas j'ai été au cinéma numéro 3 ça
semble paradoxal
là c'est plus dur un paradoxe c'est
quelque chose qui à l'air
contradictoires mais qui en réalité
n'est pas contradictoire
par exemple il est paradoxal d'être
fatigué alors qu'on n'a rien foutu de sa
journée mais ce n'est pas contradictoire
parce que ben c'est possible
donc quand vous dites ça semble
paradoxal vous dit en fait ça semble
sembler contradictoire vous voyez le
problème on dira donc c'est paradoxal où
ça semble contradictoire n'est pas ça
semble paradoxal
numéro quatre au jour d'aujourd'hui
alors si là il a le don de m'énerver
alors on va expliquer ça calmement hui
c'est l'ancien mots pour dire ce jour
aujourd'hui c'est donc déjà un pléonasme
puisque ça veut dire au jour de ce jour
mais l' usage faisant loi on a fini par
accepter l'emploi de l'expression
aujourd'hui pourtant incorrect sur le
plan grammatical mais si en plus vous
dit
au jour d'aujourd'hui vous faites un
double pléonasme puisque vous dites au
jour du jour de ce jour et là tout ce
que vous méritez
c'est un bon tacle à la carotide à josé
dit ça m'énerve numéro 5 je fais une
petite aparté
alors ici le problème est multiple
puisque déjà on ne dit pas une aparté
mais un aparté mais aussi parce que par
définition un aparté c'est toujours
petit au théâtre un aparté désigne les
paroles prononcées par un personnage et
que les autres personnages présents sur
scène ne sont pas censés entendre à
parts égales à part donc vous imaginez
bien que si la partie dure trois plombes
ça devient compliqué de faire croire au
spectateur que les autres ne l'entendent
pas pour finir il ne faut pas confondre
un aparté et une digression la plupart
du temps quand on dit qu'on fait un
aparté on veut dire qu'on va apporter un
développement annexes sujet principal
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec un aparté
puisque si les personnes présentes
entendre ce qu'on dit ce n'est plus un
aparté numéro 6 c'est de cela dont il
s'agit
alors là on est typiquement dans le
genre de fautes que même des gens
lettrés comète
voilà en quoi cet oignon de phrase est
incorrect soyez attentif c'est juste un
peu plus technique dont est un pronom
relatif qui s'utilise en reprise de la
préposition de un exemple simple je lui
ai parlé de ce restaurant devient c'est
le restaurant dont je lui ai parlé
on emploie le mot donc à dans la phrase
précédente on parlait d'eux quelque
chose donc si vous dites c'est de cela
dont il s'agit c'est comme si vous
disiez 2 x 2 la tournure correct et
c'est cela dont il s'agit
vous pouvez aussi dire c'est de cela
qu'il s'agit de cela qu'il s'agit
c'est l'un ou l'autre mais pas les deux
et ouais pour faire des choix dans la
vie
numéro 7 un moyen mnémotechnique erreurs
qu'on rentre bien compréhensible puisque
dans notre esprit mémoire mémorisation
mémo technique
ça paraît logique et bien non on dit
nemo technique nemo du nom de la déesse
grecque mais mozilla pour retrouve
d'ailleurs dans le mot amnésique qui
signifie absence de mémoire oubliée
voilà numéro 8 etc on dit est cetera est
pas ex aide ses terrasses et un pas
compliqué à aix en latin la lettre c se
prononce comme un cas on dira être
terrain ce qui veut dire littéralement
et le reste prononce à la française le
que devient un saut mais les lettres
sont les mêmes e tc etc
bon y'a pire comme hier à rodez l'accord
numéro 9 il s'en est suivi
là encore une erreur courante vous allez
voir c'est simple à comprendre qu'elle
est l'infinitif de ce verbe c'est sans
suivre en un seul mot la preuve c'est
qu'on présent on dit bien il s'en suit
que tout attaché donc il n'y a aucune
raison couper le mot en deux sous
prétexte pour le conjugue au passé
composé
on dira donc pas il s'en est suivi mais
il s'est ensuivi tout simplement
et enfin numéro 10 donc du coup alors
celui-là je les aime bien parce que
moi-même j'utilise souvent où j'utilise
souvent parce que je les aime bien je
sais pas je sais plus donc du coup c'est
évidemment une redondance plus que du
coup et donc ça me dire la même chose on
ne s'attardera pas sur le fait que
l'académie française rejette l'emploi de
l'allocution du coup comme synonyme de
don me demandez pas pourquoi c'est comme
ça ils sont le fait que quand on
commence une phrase part donc du coup
alors qu'il n'y a aucun lien de
causalité avec ce qu'on vient dire bah
c'est un peu gênant
conclusion on dira soit donc soit du
coup mais pas donc
voilà ce classement des 10 fautes de
français que nous faisons presque tous
est maintenant terminée si vous
connaissez d'autres fautes courante que
vous voulez me suggérer pour une
prochaine vidéo je vous donne rendez
vous sur ma page facebook le précepteur
j'ai créé une publication sur laquelle
vous pourrez poster vos propositions
le lien est dans la description
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner de
partager la vidéo je vous invite
également à liker la page facebook a
aimé la page facebook bordel à aimer la
page facebook
rejoignez-moi sur instagram charles
précepteur et un grand merci aux types
heures vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux merci merci infiniment
je vous dis à bientôt pour un prochain
épisode
[Musique]